wait he wanted to help people and he
wanted to [ __ ] hoes [ __ ] hoes yes
yes i i definitely have done a lot of
that bro across like i've had sex with
so many women that don't even speak
english and no that sounds pretty bad
but i'm talking about like europe and
stuff
right um
and uh
you're you're kind of a a legend in the
threesome department is that right yes
what's the secret to pulling a threesome
uh
like just a threesome or or with your
girl like having there's two types you
know it's like walk us through it okay
yeah
we're gonna need the whole menu
just for a regular threesome uh i
remember i was in london
and
uh
my my dj was uh invited two girls over
and he was gonna sleep with both of them
but he was uh occupied doing something
else so i came in the room and what like
what is it what kind of he's going to
the bathroom and that was like occupied
doing something he was he wasn't in the
room he was like that'd be pretty
important to pass up two chicks yeah the
guy probably just stepped out to make a
phone call and little zan souped in and
[ __ ] them i didn't i didn't know the
chicks were in there to be honest so uh
he's like down the street grabbing food
and they're like oh where's john coming
and i'm like oh i don't know but you
guys can chill in here and
i don't know we just it i just
love language we just
started
talking about it touching each other and
then i had sex with the two girls that
he was supposed to have sex with that's
a bad example maybe a bad friend move
definitely a bad friend i'm sorry john
um
but to a normal threesome
when you're on a tour bus and you you
know after a show they all come to your
tour bus you know to get autographs or
you know pictures and i do that i love
doing that i love i'll never deny a fan
a picture or an autograph anybody that
supports me i support them um but you
know you get this the groupies the
groupies and there's usually a part of a
tour bus and you probably notice too
that has like a back that slides back
the door it's like a little thing and
that's where all the business would go
down and like the three girls giving you
head at once for the most i ever did was
in new zealand i had a and then
every girl in this uh sick well
it was five girls plus me what is that
that's uh six something six songs and
they were very beautiful new zealand
girls and it that was the the most
amazing moment of my life six girls
sucking your dick and having sex because
they were all participating with each
other too they were bi so it was like it
was like a rotation like coming in
switching over and you know
it's like the sushi joint that has the
carousel
yeah yeah
i was very proud i i i think i went
afterwards into the bathroom and uh
looked in the mirror and was like uh
your life begins today like yeah yeah
how many times have you thought back and
jerked off to that moment
um
probably a couple times for sure
probably a couple times yeah but i i i
cherish that moment more as just
wow because i'm i got no hoes in high
school like um you know i dropped i i
did drop out in ninth grade but like
i didn't even go to high school
yeah i didn't i didn't have enough time
maybe in that week
no no yeah i didn't get enough hoes in
middle school no um you went to high
school for seven days seven days uh yeah
for real but like but i had a lot of
friends then with high school and so i
still stay in touch with i had like a
couple ugly girlfriends they were good
people though good personalities but i
wasn't getting girls you know like i
wasn't popular or any i was a nerd i
played video games
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]